هذه المنطقه الى الشمال من مخيم اللبار
شارع صلاح الدين الذي اعلنت عنه قوات
الاحتلال عبر يعني منشورات القته في
المخيم بان هذه المنطقه هي منطقه عمليات
وطلبت المواطنين النزوح من هذه المنطقه
باتجاه منطقه جنوب المحافظه الصه باتجاه
دير البلح قبل قليل عدد كبير من المواطنين
قد توجهوا عبر هذا الشارع الرئيس باتجاه
منطقه شمال المحافظه الوسطى باتجاه منطقه
وادي غز وباتجاه شمال المحافظه الوسطى
يعني المعلومات التي يتحدث بها عنها
المواطنون هنا
بان شارع صلاح الدين او قوات الاحتلال قد
فتحت حاجز يعني الحاجز المتواجد في منطقه
شمال المحافظه الصى تحديدا القرب المترق
الشهداء نسلط قلط شو اسمه عماره ماكرون
طلعوا الجنود طخ علينا قريك روح رو يعني
بتاكد انه موجودين الجنود موجت ما فيش ع
وجبات بس
جبات تروح نرو سمح لحد
يعدي ب نروح ادنا هناك يا عمي بدنا نروح
رسالتك شو رسالتك رسالت اليهود تنسحب من
هنا من عنا وخلص بكفي لو بنعمل خيمه خيمه
على كل دار مهدو بنقعد في قلبها الاخر بس
بدنا
نقعد
ازق ب غزه
قوات الاحتلال لم تنسحب من هذا الحاجز وان
كل ما يشاع هو مجرد يعني شائعات ويعني لا
يوجد صحه لهذا الخبر الذي يقول بان قوات
الاحتلال قد انسحبت من شمال المحافظه الاس
تحديدا من منطقه نت سريم او حتى حاجز
الكونتينر الى الجنوب من يعني منطقه حي
الزيتون